las violentas escenas que dejó una
manifestación contra la migración de
venezolanos en chile serán investigadas
así lo ordenó el gobierno del país y la
fiscalía pidió medidas de protección
para las víctimas al menos 13 mujeres
tres hombres y un menor de edad no
gritan bahiense para su país que hacen
aquí nos gritan muchas cosas feas
pues tristeza porque la verdad pues
todos no somos iguales hay algunas
personas que son que vienen a hacer
maldades hay otras que venimos a
trabajos muchos ya no se sienten seguros
en las calles en medio de un creciente
discurso de xenofobia que equipará la
migración a la delincuencia cuando la
marcha si yo no estaba con miedo mucho
miedo porque no sabíamos que podía pasar
la vicepresidenta venezolana del si
rodríguez el rechazo en twitter lo
ocurrido e informó que el gobierno de su
país trabaja en un plan de retorno
venezuela repudio a la xenofobia y
agresiones contra migrantes venezolanos
y exige a las autoridades nacionales y
locales de chile respeto a la integridad
física y psicológica de nuestros
connacionales presidente nicolás maduro
ordenó activar el plan vuelta a la
patria de nuestros hermanos el relator
de naciones unidas en temas de
emigración calificó el hecho como una
inadmisible humillación y un ataque a
los más vulnerables a pesar de las
constantes demandas de organizaciones
por dar un enfoque de derechos humanos a
la migración en el país el gobierno de
sebastián piñera insiste en un plan
masivo de repatriaciones este ha sido
rechazado incluso por el tribunal
supremo que dice que la política viola
los derechos básicos de los migrantes